jeudi soir en 16e de finale de la Ligue
Europa Manchester United reçoit
Saint-Étienne avec un duel inattendu
entre deux frères puisque Paul Pogba va
se retrouver face à son grand frère
florentin un match que le troisième
frère Mathias suivra de Rotterdam ou il
joue lui aussi comme attaquant
effectivement donc Paul florentin
Mathias une famille incroyable un clan
Pogba que vous avez pu rencontrer avec
la maman yo Moriba regardez le clan
Pogba un reportage donc de Fabien
Lévesque avec Michael Cariou et Fabien
Cardoen
dans l'histoire de la famille Pogba un
nouveau chapitre un rêve de gosse qui va
devenir réalité deux des trois frères
vont s'affronter pour la toute première
fois de leur carrière quand j'ai appris
la nouvelle mon frère m'a envoyé un
message directement on m'a rigolé on a
dit mais c'est fou il sentait je le
sentais
toi tu vas à la télé Manchester
Saint-Étienne Paul face à florentin
c'est un énorme dilemme pour la maman
incapable de choisir entre ces deux fils
ah qu'est-ce que je voulais devenir je
vais pas me partager à deux en tout cas
je souhaite qu'il y ait pas de perdre
match nul
[Musique]
c'est la trilogie là c'est moi
le petit et le jumeau Mathias la famille
Pogba bienvenue chez florentin
Saint-Étienne au bout du fil son jumeau
Mathias lui aussi sera jeudi à
oltraordford
un événement
c'est un événement familial mondial
comment mon bon vieux temps
où qu'il soit les frères Pogba promène
leur bonne humeur
florentin Mathias et Paul c'est un trio
fusionnel avec même ses propres codes
on danse et pour dire bonjour
[Musique]
France en octobre dernier des frères
ultra connectés et pas un joueur sans
que florentin appelle son petit frère
Paul la pioche c'est comment on dit quoi
je pense que tu es au vestiaire là je
suis avec tes amis de France 2 là
c'était pas de passer un petit bonjour
mon pote
[Musique]
s'il me répond je vous fais écouter
on a toujours été fusionnel toujours
proche les uns des autres
et puis depuis
le roi
depuis l'arrière
le quartier de la renardiera
Roissy-en-Brie à 30 km à l'est de Paris
les frères Pogba ont grandi ici au 12e
étage de cette tour là où nous emmène
sans bout à t-il un des premiers
entraîneurs de Paul
et rentrer à la maison et sortait voilà
avec cet hommage qu'ils ont que les gens
du quartier en lui
la fierté du quartier et de la ville
au cœur de la cité le terrain en tout a
commencé pour les frères Pogba là où
Paul florentin et Mathias venait répéter
leur gamme
des
le directeur sur le sur le site les
trois là c'est comme les Mousquetaires
Mathias
Flo et Paul ils étaient tout le temps
les deux grands pouvaient
couver le petit donc
je crois ils étaient ils étaient
inséparables on était quasiment tous les
jours au city stade des fois on allait
jouer à
trois mois et mes frères dans les
travailler la technique faire des
jongles pieds gauche pied droit de la
tête
ça a été leur passion depuis tout petit
et heureusement que ça aboutit
le travail à payer les trois frères sont
aujourd'hui footballeurs professionnels
Paul milieu de terrain florentin
défenseur et Mathias attaquant mais qui
était le plus fort des trois à l'époque
c'est mes frères et mes frères
moi je dis que c'est tous les trois
parce que c'est eux
ils ont toujours été au-dessus avec
toujours et au-dessus de moi et j'ai
perdu tous je parlais très souvent
contre eux et je veux que avec les
personnes de leur âge donc voilà c'est
donc ça m'a aidé donc je vais avec les
plus les plus âgés ils étaient plus
costauds et tout non c'est ça qui a fait
que
on a progressé un peu plus je pense je
pense que c'est aussi ça aidé
Paul c'est l'icône du quartier il est le
joueur le plus cher du monde et grâce à
lui l'US Roissy-en-Brie a touché l'été
dernier une indemnité de formation de
400000 euros il est ici un exemple de
réussite et son fameux dab une référence
pour toute une génération
comme mes amis me montrent et ces
choses-là je suis je suis choqué on m'a
dit c'est passé aussi dans un cours de
maths c'est ça qui m'a qui c'était plus
marrant en fait je me suis dit pour
passer un message pour éduquer les gens
même à l'école si on peut utiliser ça
une manière ou les élèves vont être
concentrés c'est une bonne chose c'était
pas très très fort en maths mais au
moins si je m'aider les gens les enfants
en maths c'est c'est quelque chose de
top parce que maman a fait le DAB aussi
le fait mieux que moi tu fais avec moi
on y va
retour à Saint-Étienne sortie de
l'entraînement Paul alias la pioche
vient de laisser un message à florentin
alias
[Musique]
ment on vient d'entraînement musique
même si j'en ai pour 3 minutes c'est 3
minutes de bonheur
le rythme dans la peau chez les Pogba à
tel point que les trois frères ont créé
leur propre mouvement la pogbase
la fratrie et comme on aime bien danger
donc donc
[Musique]
tout simplement
famille c'est tout ils ont toujours été
là
ma mère nettoyer mes couches
ah oui elle est taillée tout ça c'était
mes frères ils m'ont des fois ils m'ont
servi à il me servait à manger je me
rappelle quand on joue au ping-pong mais
on joue on faisait du ping-pong avant
mes frères il était champion de France
et ils ont reçu un chèque ils m'ont ils
m'ont acheté une paire de chaussures
j'ai toujours dit je vais je vais vous
redonner la moule et la pièce et je
serai toujours là pour vous donc voilà
ça ça reste dans ma tête et je vais pas
oublier
[Musique]